nine minutes and 29 seconds changed the
world two years ago george floyd an
african-american man was killed right
here in minneapolis by a white police
officer who knelt on floyd's neck and
back for nine minutes and 29 seconds the
name george floyd became a symbol for
the fight for racial justice and against
police brutality against black people
his killing emboldened the black lives
matter movement all around the world the
washington post reporter robert samuels
is one of the two authors of the deeply
reported book his name is george floyd
one man's life and the struggle for
racial justice
robert thank you so much for making time
for deutsche weather today um
before
we start
talking about
george floyd's death and the
implications and all the promises which
were made afterwards i would like to
start
talking about him as a person so who was
george floyd we spoke with a lot of
friends and family of george floyd and
they all
talked about him in very similar ways
they talked about him being a very
friendly person
someone who would always
recognize if you're doing something
different on the street if you had new
shoes or a new hairstyle
they talked about him being a jokester
and having a good sense of humor
and they talked about how they all how
he always wanted to tell people he loved
them
that was how he ended almost every
conversations because he every
conversation because he had known that
growing up in his neighborhood
people don't hear i love you a lot so
that's how he would end every
conversation
when did he really struggle with his
life maybe you can talk a little bit
about his early adult life one of the
things we look at in the book is that
when george floyd was in second grade
he wanted to become a supreme court
justice that was his dream because he
had learned about thurgood marshall the
first black supreme court justice and he
wanted to be like him
he was also reading at grade level
which was really hard if you grew up in
a community that didn't have a lot of
resources he was one of the few kids in
his class who is reading at grade level
on national benchmarks
but over the course of the his life as
george floyd grows up he eventually
becomes six six
225 pounds he's a big guy
people see him and instead of
encouraging him to study textbooks they
give him a football they give him a
basketball and they say to him you
should become an athlete you should go
this is how you're going to get a
college scholarship this is how you're
going to go to become a professional a
professional sports player this is how
you're going to live lift yourself out
of poverty
and
george floyd believes that that's the
promise that's given to him but
the sad truth is by the time he gets to
college
he does not have the academic
requirements to be able to succeed in
college
so he never plays
and he's in these remedial classes while
his mother gets sick
and the mother is also taking care of
some of george floyd's nieces and
nephews
feeling that
he needs to do more to
help the family
he goes back to cuny homes
but he can't find a job without a
college degree and he can't find a job
in the neighborhood
so
he does what a lot of people in the
neighborhood do he starts selling drugs
and
because he's sad and because
he looks for an escape like so many of
the people in the neighborhood he also
starts using them as a way to get his
mind off things
and that leads to a cycle you know both
of a cycle of drug dependency and an
addiction
but also a cycle of going in and out of
prison
because during that time
the federal government was putting
putting on the war on drugs and then
came the crime bill
in which they put lots of officers on
the street and delivered harsh sentences
to people who are doing drugs and using
drugs
uh george floyd he gets caught in that
system
and he ends up spending more than a
third of his adult life in prison mostly
for
offenses that were never violent mostly
for drug deals that are about 10 or 20
dollars
and even though he says and we looked at
the intake forms and all the records in
the book even though he says
i need help i have an addiction i'm
hearing voices
no one believes him
which is a common thing
when you look at the science and the
research in terms of how
doctors
treat black people particularly black
men often times when they say they're in
pain or they have
they're struggling they don't believe
them until the very end they didn't
believe him until he was was killed yeah
a white police officer who kneeled i
think all of our viewers are very aware
of that more than nine minutes on his
neck and
george floyd was crying for help he
reached out to his mama and he wasn't
believed nobody believed him
so um
robert
after he got killed after this video
went viral
there was a lot of
solidarity
there
were many protests all around the world
and there was a presidential campaign
and then candidate
joe biden promised a lot for example
uh
a police reform
nothing happened
well
joe biden
he creates he
creates a very tight bond with a lot of
the family particularly george floyd's
brothers uh philonous and rodney
and we talk about their interactions in
the book
and the day derek chauvin gets convicted
uh joe biden gives the family a call
and he says we're going to do this we're
going to pass this big
piece of legislation to do police reform
in george floyd's name
and not only that we're going to do it
in the way you wanted to do it to mark
the one year anniversary of his murder
but
things never go that easily in
washington
and even though there is a lot of
solidarity in this country to end
systemic racism and to do things to
prevent something like the incident that
happened between george floyd and derek
sherman from ever happening again
it got bogged down in
f infighting in bureaucracy
in the differences between how much uh
how much
responsibility a police officer should
be able to
withstand because they committed a crime
and the bill ultimately fails what does
all that mean for the african-american
community especially in minneapolis i
mean you and your colleague you spend so
much time down there yeah
well
so many people marched in the streets in
minneapolis and across the country and a
lot of the and all over the world
because they believed that
after witnessing such a horrible murder
that this could be the chance maybe this
is the time for the world to change
and that eventually confronted the sad
reality about how things go in america
that when the concept of racism
comes up people feel blamed they feel
shamed they don't want to talk about it
in full in the fullest way
and so
when you consider all of that
so many times
the black community
they are forced to accept what they get
what does all that mean for
a democracy like which always comes down
to voting i mean there was so much hope
after derek showman was finally
convicted it's really unclear
one of the con interesting conversations
that we had was with
reverend l sharpton who had
long tried to make police violence
some of the one of the central civil
rights issues
and
at first
people thought of it as a localized
issue
and then he talks about how it took the
back seat because there are more
important things that are a higher
priority like the right to vote
now in this country
we're seeing that history repeat itself
we're seeing discussions about voting
rights re-emerge feeling that
uh there are laws and uh their
legislation being put forward to make it
harder for people for of color to vote
in this country
and again there's
they're fighting the same sort of
battles that
most people thought were settled 50
years ago
and so it's really unclear what happens
now
if you look at what's happening in
georgia where george floyd's murder
helped to inspire so many people to go
out and vote and elect two democratic
senators one of
the first black senators still in this
country post reconstruction as well as
elect joe biden to office in a cradle of
the south
uh you saw more restrictive voting
rights and over the primary you saw more
people saying we're not going to take it
we're going to find ways
to be able to vote
so again it goes back to this very
strange principle that we have in this
country
which is
you make
you have laws that make it harder for
black people to live their lives
and then you expect them to go through
great lengths to be able to achieve some
of the same fundamental rights and
values that white people have
unfortunately that's the perennial story
of this country
what role will uh the growing cultural
war play in all that i mean i'm also
talking about this big replacement
theory which outcome which horrible
outcome we just experienced in buffalo
where an 18 year old
killed
10 african americans
i i don't know
um
what we know
is that
there is a real fear
in this country about what will happen
when the plurality of people in this
country are no longer white
and we saw the most extreme version of
that playing out in buffalo but it plays
out in small ways all across the country
right
and a part of that has to do with some
of the things we talk about in the book
you know i've grown up
here
all my life
love this country
and yet there are so many instances when
we looked at george floyd's history and
what was going around that i didn't know
and it makes me wonder
if we had the full story
if we were taught from
the very beginning
that anyone can do anything
but sometimes there were laws that made
it harder for certain people to do
something
maybe we'd have a better shot at having
a better tomorrow
so
i think the question really comes down
to how are we going to educate people
how are we going to inform them about
the fact that
what happened in the past still has
impacts today
and how can we do it in a way that
doesn't feel like people should be
shamed or angry or guilty
i say it's one of the strangest things
that
the books that
ev
we're told everyone should read in 2020
are now the books that continue to be
banned in 2022
what's that about and i think we have to
have real conversations in the country
about why it's happening
and
be ready to acknowledge and confront
some of the country's demons that's what
the book tries to do
um but i you know as a journalist i
believe that's a part of it if you want
a fairer and more democratic society
that's what we have to do so robert you
and your
co-author tolu you're both two african
american
young men
how did uh
working on this book change your lives
when i started this project
i too
thought of racism as just a dark cloud
and that was just static and hung over
us
but as i
spent time with the floyd family and
people who loved them
as i met
more mothers
who looked like my mom
who had lost sons who looked like me
to police violence over dubious
practices
you start
to see something and you start to see
that racism moves in a way it doesn't
just stay in a place it moves and it
breathes within people
and if you don't do something to
acknowledge and confront it
it will corrupt your spirit
uh
it will threaten you it could kill you
and so
this became
so much more
of a reminder of why journalism is
important because
we believe we make a bet with the reader
that if we present you information in a
way that's accurate and delicate
uh
it might unlock something in you in the
way that you might view the world
and so that's what we tried to do it
became more of a mission it deepened my
mission for journalism
and
i became acutely aware
that
if more people didn't understand
it could be my life that's next
and
i think about it you know somebody asked
me the other day
what i think the difference
between me and george floyd was
and
it's not
that i had a father even though i did
have a father in my life
that's helpful but it's not the reason
i'm alive
it's not that i
had a great education i did have a great
education but i also went to title one
schools just like george floyd
the reason i'm alive today and george
floyd is not is because i didn't see
derek chovin on may 25th 2020
and that's a horrifying thing to be able
to recognize
are you more or less hopeful after
finishing this book
i'm more
i really am
because
when
you
see the persistence
of the floyd family
over the years
george floyd had every reason
not to try
any reason not to believe in the
american system
and the promise of it but he did until
the day he died
and how do we know that we know that
because he responded to the officer
in the way he was always told to respond
to officers by saying please and thank
you and sir
and respecting them
even when
they were killing him
and after that you saw so many people
take up that cause because they knew it
wasn't right
and what that showed to me
is that there's still some
hope of light there's still some light
there that is prob maybe untapped you
have to consider
that people were moved to march after
they saw george floyd die
you have to consider the places that i
used to protest
because of discriminated
because of discrimination and bad laws
uh are now places that have black mayors
and black police chiefs
there was a time where
two
black men who look like you who are your
age
would never get the support from a
publisher
to write what you had written
and so i think there's a lot to be
hopeful for
robert samuels thank you so much not
only for this interview but also for
writing this book it's
so deeply reported
i learned so much when i was reading it
and it's a good read as well
it will be translated into german as
well and i hope it gets many many
readers all around the world thank you
very much thanks so much i appreciate it